there is still another forum than that
just indicated in which the indifference
of law and force or of notion and being
is to be found in the law of motion for
example it is necessary that motion be
split up into time and space or again
into distance and velocity thus since
motion is only the relation of these
factors it the universal is certainly
divided in its own self but now these
parts time and space or distance and
velocity do not in themselves Express
this origin in a one they are
indifferent to one another
space is thought of is able to be
without time time without space and
distance at least without velocity just
as their magnitudes are indifferent to
one another since they are not related
to one another as positive and negative
and thus are not related to one another
through their own essential nature the
necessity of the division is thus
certainly present here but not the
necessity of the parts as such for one
another but it is just for this reason
that first necessity to its is itself
only a sham false necessity for motion
is not itself thought of as something
simple or as a pure essence but has
already divided time and space are in
themselves its independent parts or
essences or distance and velocity or
modes of being or ways of thinking
either which can well be without the
other and motion is therefore only their
superficial relation not their essence
if it is thought of as a simple essence
or as force motion is no doubt gravity
but this does not contain these
differences at all
in section 153 we're back to considering
motion gravity but the mainly motion
something even broader perhaps we've
talked about electricity as an example
and remember - we're not really worried
about whether Hegel is getting theory of
electricity fundamentally right or
whether he's doing an adequate account
to this point because he's interested in
thinking about these as examples for how
we conceptualize laws right here as I
pointed out already
he's drawing out some further
implications of the fact that the way
motion becomes something with law-like
regularities that we can conceptualize
in the understanding and then perhaps
predict or you know grasp the seeming
necessity of and communicated to others
that motion works differently than
electricity and he's going to use this
as a substantive example to illustrate
it yet further you know the the what we
can grasp what we can dialectically
advanced to in terms of the way that
force and law really work in terms of
necessity so we have what we've seen you
know the force expresses itself in a
certain way the motion understood as law
of motion breaks itself up into two
sides the force is the unifying thing
that overcomes the differences it's
abstract
the law itself works by bringing about
differences that are supposed to matter
that are supposed to be relevant that
are supposed to be exactly the sort of
thing that we want angle points out here
that everything about motion it works a
little bit differently though he says
there's another form that then that just
indicated in which the indifference of
law enforcement and being us to be found
in the law of motion it's necessary that
motion be split up into space and time
space versus time essentially right
although not as positive to negative so
there's a
necessity here right for this splitting
let's do this it's necessary that motion
at least for the way that we're
understanding it in terms of the
physical phenomena be split into space
and time and then he says or again into
distance and velocity right so that's
that's another possibility and we've got
the splitting here here's something that
Hegel doesn't talk about the but you
might want to think about at this point
is it necessary that law for emotion
express itself in these two different
ways and are they themselves opposed
he's not actually going to explore that
imperfect as it doesn't need to at this
point but it's something that you could
think about so he goes on he says since
motion is only the relation of these
factors the universal is certainly
divided in its own self right force in
this case the force of motion is
expressed in terms of these factors and
their interrelationships other we can
have equations in the part of the
expression those equations seem to give
us a necessity so he says the universal
is divided but now these parts time and
space distance and velocity do not in
themselves Express this origin in a what
why not
electricity did because the positive of
the negative were both like parts of one
whole right there they're opposed to
each other the time and space they don't
necessarily have to be opposed to each
other as a matter of fact you can think
of time without necessarily thinking of
space at least Hegel think so I mean
there are certain theories of time where
time is you know directly connected with
space sure right but Hegel is pointing
out that at least in the abstract you
can think the passage of time without
thinking space as a matter of fact if
you think about what's going on with
Renee de cartes
you know evil demon hypothesis time is
passing for the Cartesian subject for
whom there may be no spaciality
whatsoever right so we can in fact
conceive of time as separate from space
could we conceive of space as separate
from time why not
purely static universe nothing ever
happens nothing changes that's a live
possibility at least for the intellect
or the understanding isn't it so he says
you know times time without space
distance at least without velocity just
as you know in practice their magnitudes
are indifferent to one another so
they're not related to each other it's
positive and negative they're not
related to on each other through their
own essential nature now what is the
upshot of this so the necessity of the
division is certainly present here right
we did have to divide motion to
conceptualize it adequately right - to
bring all of the particulars that we
want into the law in order to do that to
make them intelligible and to make their
differences you know like say red and
blue or or you know tasty and not so
tasty no longer matter and make them
just be factors of these things we had
to introduce these these distinctions we
had to introduce those and that is
what's expressed in the equations that
that kind of comprise the abstract
notion of the force right so that act
was necessary but there's no necessary
relationship between time and space or
distance and velocity you can arrange
these in all different sorts of ways
there is no necessity there right so in
a certain sense
the stuff that we're actually working
with isn't necessary what are they what
are the implications for this he says
it's just for this reason that the first
necessity to is itself only a sham false
necessity this isn't even necessary
because the the relation between these
parts are these factors are these
moments it is not necessary the division
between them is itself not necessary now
we're in trouble aren't we because you
know we want necessity and we think that
you know we're thinking about the laws
of motion that all those seem to really
you know express necessity and now we're
finding out that they don't according to
Hegel he says why is this motion is not
itself thought of as something simple or
as a pure essence but in a different way
has already divided what we experience
in terms of motion I move towards you
right did you experience you know
distinct magnitudes of time and space I
mean in a certain respect they be there
being mapped out by the camera right
that's why we can do things frame by
frame and do all sorts of cool things
with photoshop and editing and stuff
like that yes there's you know but this
is just a facsimile a movement it's not
the real movement that was that I was
actually making although that movement
is gone we you know we saw that was sent
certainty right but real movement the
thing that the war is supposed to really
help us conceptualize is not actually a
matter of magnitudes of time and space
or distance and velocity those help us
to describe it those you might say are
kind of like a armature or a grid or a
set of mathematical tools that we use to
make sense of
but actual motion is not that it
approximates to it or rather they
approximate to yet to motion but they
don't express the necessity of motion so
he says motion is not itself thought of
as something simple or as a pure essence
but has already divided time and space
are in themselves its independent parts
or essences or distance and velocity our
modes of being our ways of thinking
either of which can be well can can well
be without the other and motion is
therefore only their superficial
relation not their essence we want to
grasp the essence of things when we're
grasping forces in the laws he says if
it's thought of as a simple essence or a
force motion is no doubt gravity but
that doesn't contain these differences
at all that's not gonna help just
recurring a gravity so what have we seen
here electricity had certain issues with
it whenever talking about that is sort
of letting us grasp the the essential
nature of things
same thing with motion itself we're
finding some some interesting wrinkles
in this we're thinking that we have our
hands on necessity and then I was
turning out that that's not really the
case
the difference then in both cases is not
a difference in its own self either the
universal force is indifferent to the
division which is the law or the
differences the parts of the law are
indifferent to one another
the understanding however has the notion
of this implicit difference just because
the law is on the one hand the inter
implicit being but is at the same time
inwardly differentiated that this
difference is thus an inner difference
follows from the fact that the law is a
simple force or is the notion of the
difference and is therefore a difference
belonging to the notion but this inner
difference still falls to begin with
only within the understanding and is not
yet posited in the thing itself it is
therefore only its own necessity that is
asserted by the understanding the
difference then is posited by the
understanding in such a way that at the
same time it is expressly stated that
the difference is not a difference
belonging to the thing itself this
necessity which is merely verbal is thus
a recital of the moments constituting
the cycle of the necessity the moments
are indeed distinguished but at the same
time their difference is expressively
said to be not a difference of the thing
itself and it consequently is itself
immediately canceled again this process
is called explanation a law is
enunciated from this it's a implicitly
universal element or ground is
distinguished as force but it is said
that this difference is no difference
rather that the ground is constituted
exactly the same as law the single
occurrence of lightning for example is
apprehended as a universal and this
universal is enunciated as the law of
electricity the explanation that
condenses the law into force as the
essence of the law this force then is so
constituted that when it is expressed
opposite electricity's appear which
disappear again into one another that is
force is constituted exactly the same as
law there is said to be no difference
whatever between them the differences
are the pure universal expression of law
and pure force but both have the same
content or the same Constitution thus
the difference qua difference of content
the thing is again is also again
withdrawn
section 154 begins by talking about this
difference or differences that we've
just revealed as not really being
necessary this is one of the issues with
law what we think that we're grasping as
having a certain assessing to it that
allows us to get to the heart of things
turns out not to have that sort of
necessity so he says the difference that
in both cases what are what are both
cases in both cases of what we were
looking at in the last section the the
differences between the ways in which
the motion was being expressed he says
it's not a difference in its own self
either the universal force is
indifferent to the division which is the
law right so the force is indifferent to
the law is indifferent to the
differences that are built into the law
or the differences the parts of the law
are indifferent to each other we've got
a double problem in either case right
neither one gives us a necessity then if
it's merely indifferent so he says the
understanding however he has the notion
of this implicit difference just because
the law is on the one hand the inner
implicit being what I've got here is
we've got the the the workings of the
law he has in the world as in themselves
and then we have the understanding and
it's sort of reconstruction for itself
it's grasped you might say how it takes
in what it's finding how its
conceptualizing it so the understanding
to go back to this he says in the
understanding has the notion of this
implicit difference so there is a
difference between them going on just
because the law is on the one hand the
inner implicit being but it's inwardly
differentiated see so the law itself has
differences that are inner inwardly
differentiated from each other that's
the way the others
deeming his making sense of it on the
other hand the force as he says that
this difference is an inner difference
follows from the fact that law is a
simple force or is the notion of the
difference the the grasp the concept of
the difference the way in which the
understanding is actually making sense
of this so it's a difference belonging
to the notion now here's where it gets
really interesting he said we've got a
difference going down here we also have
something that appears to be necessity
and at this point and he says this inner
difference still Falls to begin with
only within the understanding it has not
yet posited in the thing itself
in what it is that we're trying to study
in what it is that we're trying to make
sense of it's a little bit more
complicated when the thing we're trying
to study to say human beings right or
the laws of consciousness but put that
aside from them so he says it's
therefore only its own necessity that is
asserted by the understanding so before
what we saw is we thought we had a
necessity here within the differences we
thought we had necessity in two
different ways namely that the
differences had to be differentiated
from each other and they had to be
differentiated the way that they were
and that they had a necessary relation
to each other and that you can say is
really an expression of the fact that
that force does express itself that it
expresses itself through some sort of
bifurcation or trifurcation or however
many things we want to distinguish there
all right what we saw that we don't
really have this Hegel is saying that
the understanding in its reconstruction
of what's going on out here it
introduces a kind of necessity but that
is coming from the understanding itself
that should always be a little suspect
right whenever we find that we're trying
to make sense out of some sort of
complex set of phenomena and we're
observing some some regularities and we
think that we have the general structure
of things but then we discover that the
reason we think so is because that's an
artifact of our own production an
artifact of our own processes of the way
that we framed it for ourself we should
be worried about that assuming that that
necessity is out here in in the thing
itself there's plenty of cases where we
create imaginary worlds that work
according to certain laws but those laws
don't turn out to be the way things
really are so that's that's a recurring
issue
so yoga zone' says this inner difference
falls only within the understanding it's
not yet positive whether the thing
itself so it's only its own a sesame
it's the understandings own necessity
that is asserted by the understanding
the difference then is posited by the
understanding in such a way that at the
same time it's expressly stated the
difference is not a difference belonging
to the thing itself so we have a session
here now between the thing itself in the
way that the understanding is making
sense of that thing the concept if we
want to talk in those terms the concept
is not mapping on exactly to the thing
and what we've got here is a complex
metaphysical concept of law of the way
things are supposed to be articulated
how they work in their their heart of
their being so he goes on he says this
necessity which was merely verbal is
thus a recital of the moments
constituting the cycle of the necessity
whatwhat does that mean the necessity is
falling here on the side of the
understanding and the understanding is
going through a process of
recapitulating to itself when it's
working to try to make sense of some
sort of phenomenon in terms of law it's
providing itself what Hegel is about to
call an explanation this is a
recapitulation a recital of the moments
constituting the cycle of the
necessities as the moments are indeed
distinguished but at the same time their
difference is said not to be a
difference of the thing itself
consequently in it is itself immediately
cancelled this process this cycle of
providing sort of a vision for itself of
how these things are connected with each
other when they're not necessarily so
over here is an explanation so he says a
law is enunciated from this right so we
have a law how does it happen it's
implicitly Universal Elementor ground is
distinguished in this force but it is
said that this difference is no
difference the ground is constituted
exactly the same as the law the single
occurrence of lightning over here right
this is the lightning as occurring in
reality we could say occurring external
to us here's the lightning as occurring
for us within the scope of our
understanding and the lightning is then
broken down into the force of
electricity and the you know way in
which electricity is actually expressed
with the polarity is positive negative I
forget whether it's positive electricity
that that's trying to get to the
negative or the other way around for
lightning
I don't remember my my earth science but
that's what we're construing for ourself
that's an explanation we're providing to
ourself
that's not actually the thing itself so
he says a single occurrence is
apprehended as what as a universal as
the law of electricity the explanation
then condenses the law into force as the
essence of the law the force is so
constituted that when it's expressed
opposite
these appear which disappear again into
each other that is force in the
understanding it has in fact constituted
the same way as law not what's going on
over here
so we've got again a difference being
introduced between what's happening for
the understanding and what's happening
for law of course all of this is for
consciousness so there's a good question
here well how are we able to compare
these with each other how is the
external able to be differentiated from
the internal or the internal of what
really is from our external viewpoint
two-putt those are important questions
and Hegel is going to consider those two
but what he really wants to stress here
is that any appearance of necessity is
coming from the understanding sort of
imposing that and what we have going on
is the fact that law and force are now
essentially being equated with each
other and substitutable for each other
so he says the differences are the pure
universal expression of water right
differences and pure force both have the
same content the same Constitution thus
the difference quad difference of
content of the thing is awful also
withdrawn so we come again to one of
these moments where we say look things
are not not only not as we thought they
were but the things that we were taking
as being stable points have started
shift and this cannot be an adequate
explanation let's use a word in a
different way this cannot be an adequate
account for ourselves because the things
that we're using to articulate that
account are unraveling there as Hegel
says vanishing so we're going to have to
go further now in figuring out what's
going on with law and force